well if you've been to a local mall
lately you may have noticed things are
a lot different now while there were
changes being made to many malls before
the pandemic
this past year forced even more changes
for shopping centers
joe mohler is live outside of the
meadows mall with more on what we can
expect in the future
joe well malls around the valley and
really around the nation were really hit
hard by the pandemic we are outside the
meadows mall like you had just mentioned
some properties are getting creative
with activity oriented shops like this
bowling alley you may remember
this was once a sears while the pandemic
may have caused some closures it's now
sparking opportunity
it was quiet it was quiet i noticed a
couple stories that weren't open at all
well we came real early
so it wasn't a lot of people at the time
taking a look at the indoor malls around
the valley it is easy to spot vacant
stores
it was very very scary for everybody
michael minden owns michael emindon
jewelers in fashion show on the las
vegas strip
the mall in itself is probably about
maybe 80 percent of where it was
minton says some stores did not survive
the pandemic most of the vacancies that
we've experienced
apparently have been national stores
minden's store closed for three months
it wasn't until june 1st when he could
reopen a lot of the wonderful clients
that would normally be
visiting fashion show we're still scared
and we're wanting to stay home
almost a year later his regular
customers are starting to return and
enjoy
in-person shopping once again shopping
expert trey bodge says vacancies provide
opportunity businesses are experimenting
because they have lower prices per
square foot
and so an unusual business can kind of
pop into a mall and see what happens
as restrictions loosen up bodge expects
shopping centers will do more
mall owners are trying to find a way to
bring more foot traffic into the malls
by
offering a broader selection outdoor
malls on the other hand have been
popular spots according to commercial
real estate agent and broker dana berger
we live in a fantastic climate so who
wouldn't want to be
outside she has noticed the changes at
some indoor malls
boulevard mall now their empty big box
stores
are call centers we're seeing
distribution centers now
in vacant big box retail spaces
the indoor locations provide a different
sort of opportunity it's
just reinventing what's there the
valley's biggest mall
fashion show was unique due to its strip
location the silver lining is that now
it breeds opportunity
brent gardner is the senior general
manager we're constantly evolving from
activities to unique products he says he
expects retailers to adapt and become
innovative to attract customers
see retailers you know whether it be
here in vegas or anywhere
frankly those that that do the best and
and do well into the future you know
they they pay close attention to what
their consumers and what their clients
request and
and the feedback they provide
back out here live as restrictions ease
experts expect more people to head back
out to the local mall so they can do
things like try on clothes once again
and get to that
in-person shopping experience like
they're used to that happened before
the pandemic reporting live outside the
meadows mall joe mullen 8 news now